bap bap bap finally gonna weigh in on
tiger king you know how much this
dresses me out if you know me at all the
craziest part of all this has actually
been people's reaction to watching tiger
king everyone's texting me and they're
like oh my god did you see that tiger
king documentary that guy there owns
Tigers it's crazy how is that news did
you hear what you just said the guy that
owns Tigers is crazy it was in the
sentence the craziest part about it the
only reason people now think that people
that own Tigers are crazy is because
they're seeing how shittily they dress
like for someone to think that someone
that privately-owned Tigers was crazy
they had to wear suede fringe jackets
and a bowl cut with Jessica Simpson hair
extension mullets like that's the thing
that tipped people off that these people
might have a screw loose bad fashion and
shitty hair is the only thing that will
convince human beings that someone's
crazy you're like oh my god did you see
his crazy pants and the crazy shirt he
was wearing yeah and I also saw the
Tigers and chicken wire standing behind
him his hair is the least crazy thing
about this scenario what did you think
people that abused and exploited Tigers
dressed like you thought that they were
swinging by Ann Taylor Loft going to
pick up some chinos at Banana Republic
you think they were picking up a little
v-neck a little a little subtle V a
j.crew what did you think these people
are psychopaths the gold Liam a shirts
is the least crazy thing about this
scenario but human beings no matter how
much evidence we have that someone is
crazy or a bad person we only care about
their facial hair we own
they care about shitty fashion like with
Hitler all anyone talks about is the
mustache that mustache that's not what
made Hitler an
Phil Spector killed his wife for like
that hair I think he's guilty
the hair huh Donald Trump if Donald
Trump had good hair everyone would love
him they loved him they'd be like I
don't know maybe it was a good idea to
hire all the pandemics experts I don't
know I think he knows what he's talking
about people keep asking me if the men
entire King abuse the Tigers I can't
handle this of course they do yes
absolutely
but they hold the Cubs yeah this is a
jersey nut is that you guys know what's
up
you know it's abuse but we have this
ability as human beings to override
common sense when we want something to
be true really badly we know that mom
Tigers and mom lions are very protective
of their cubs
so if you see a man and a lamb a tank
top holding a cub what do you think
happened you think that the the mama
tiger was like you know what I do love
my precious Cubs but I'm gonna
consensually give them to you so that
you can pimp them out to Instagram horse
and bikini models so they can get likes
I really want to help their career I
want to make sure they get a a detox tea
campaign you take my baby tigers I'll be
I'll be cool about it I don't really
love them that much they kill them they
killed the moms they drugged them they
kill them how else do you think they're
able to get the Cubs away from their
moms no lion tiger or bear mom is just
gonna voluntarily give their cubs away
to talentless Instagram influencers
horrible things had to happen guys
use au noggin we truly only care about
people's haircuts it's all we care about
it's the only thing we look at like
there's a shot of da cantle the Myrtle
Beach Safari psycho on an elephant and
everyone's look look at his ponytail I
didn't see the ponytail all I saw was
the bull hook where he's electrocuting
the elephant to make it do anyone's look
in his hands but his ponytail a ponytail
two crazy ponytails the least crazy
thing in that shot he's riding an
elephant whoo elephants are herd animals
they shouldn't be alone much less having
this ride them exotic
animal owners you have to understand
these are the scummiest people on the
planet these are people that were so
profoundly terrible and had such shitty
personalities that they had to get
Tigers to make people like them or pay
attention them they had no skull they
had no talent so they have to force
Tigers to each other so that they
can get attention and some income these
are the people in high school like there
were the jocks and the Nerds the future
tiger people were like the meth heads
that smelled like pee those were the
people that grew up to be these tiger
pimps future tiger people in high school
they were the weirdos that had like mood
rings on and like a tiger's eye necklace
the ball and like a hand that they got
at the mall kiosk they were the ones
that when you were in gym class and you
were changing your shoes you'd see that
he had like a toe ring on and you were
like it's December right wearing a toe
ring inside like was that just for you
you're just a toe ring guy all year
round
these people are hucksters talentless
lacking empathy hucksters these are
people that were too stupid to be drug
dealers that's how they would have made
money fast but they couldn't these are
the guys
were so dumb that they would cut cocaine
with like too much detergent and would
kill someone because they just couldn't
be a good huckster these are the people
that couldn't be burglars because they'd
go burgle someone's house and they come
back with like pots and pans and the
head burglar would be like why don't you
take a computer
you sloppy huckster you can't
even Huck right people that think it's a
good idea to have tigers in their
basement these are the people that like
today would be the kids eating Tide Pods
or the kid that like was on spring break
and was like I want to get Corona I'll
get it I'll beat it that guy's
gonna grow up to think it's a good idea
to put a tiger in his closet
and rent it out for $20 an hour like
that's how dumb these people are and
every time at Carroll Baskin she killed
one guy okay
all right the other men have been
abusing in killing Tigers for the past
30 years and there's only six thousand
in the wild there's about three billion
men in the wild men aren't going extinct
Tigers are I swear to god it it you only
think someone's a bad person if they
look stupid right so if I say to you
right now you guys I'm gonna I think I'm
gonna kill someone you'd be like no
she's not no she's not she's kidding
but if I do this if this is my hairstyle
and this is my purse which this is a
person I had by the way if I look like
this if I went hey guys I think I'm
gonna kill someone you'd believe me this
is what it has to come to for us to
think someone's crazy they have to have
shitty hair and they have to look chitti
this is really mine by the way
oh this I got this at a charity save the
Tigers charity thing oh my gosh and then
there's a necklace in here with a tiger
on it oh my god there's two necklaces
with Tigers on it look at that not
pretty I am Carol Baskin okay with that